hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar keeping up with the chemist
cloud processing from pharma cryo e m
i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by elaborates and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more
about our sponsor visit them at
thermofisher.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during this presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
now this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits i'd now like to
welcome our speakers today
first tayana maya an associate director
at astrazeneca
and steve lister at aws principal hpc
business leader for healthcare and life
sciences
joining these two will be brian shervin
an aaws specialist solutions architect
and natalie white aws enterprise
solutions architect
and finally yes
a cryo em application scientist at
thermo fisher scientific
welcome to all of you
you may now begin your presentations
hi everybody i'm tayana maya jolivada
and i'm heading the cryo-em group at
astrazeneca in cambridge uk
i'm very happy to be here today so many
thanks to the organizers for the
invitation
in this talk i will elaborate a bit on
how structural biology and cryo-em fits
into the drug discovery process
and how important it is to have
structures at the right stage of the
process
at the final part of the talk i will
also share some of the experience uh in
implementing and expanding the use of
cryogem at astrazeneca
and compare the state of things uh in
the beginning to how they are now
so
as you know drug discovery is a lengthy
complex and costly process
developing a new drug can actually take
12 to 15 years
on top of that this process is permeated
with a high degree of uncertainty that a
compound will actually succeed as a drug
the success rate for candidates is
around 10
so in this slide what we have is an
overview of the different stages of drug
development process
until the approval and post-market
surveillance
this diagram also shows some of the
specific concerns
and some steps that each stage
prioritizes so for example we have in
target
identification
we need to find out the disease linkage
the drug ability and the validation of
the target
so we are focusing here on structural
biology and therefore cryogem
and i want to tell you that uh the
stages in which cryogem and structural
biology have the greatest impact is
really in the early stages of the
process of drug discovery
so as you can see in the slide this
would be the phases of
target identification heat
identification lead identification and
optimization
the uses of structural biology they will
include for example the assessment of
drug ability of the target in in a
question and also
that happening at the target
identification stage
the final validation of the compounds
that were identified through the
screening campaign
they are also they can also be done by
structural biology and they are done at
the
stage of heat identification
however we will focus a little bit on
the stage that has the most extensive
use of structural biology and that use
is really optimizing a compound into a
molecule that has drug-like properties
in the lead optimization stage
so
in this
slide what i want to do is really
illustrate this process and how we use
the structures
also after you
i present this i want you to have a
feeling for how
iterative is the nature of this process
so
um in this case here we have a heat
in the first box which you can see and
we've we managed to get a structure
from the compound in complex with the
protein of interest
and what you can see with the arrow is
that there is an
empty space
on the pocket right next to the compound
now this was a compound that was picked
up during the heat
identification stage through screening
and
it has very poor potency so you can see
the ic50 is around 5 micromolar
now having the the information from the
structure and seeing that there is this
empty space
uh
there was something obvious to do there
which was to try to optimize this stage
into getting a better shape
complementarity
so for this
we introduce a phenol group
that could really
fulfill that pocket properly
now what is usual with this process is
that
that when you solve one problem
you get another one and in this case by
adding that group we now have a compound
that is a very has very low solubility
now the structural information can also
help there because
from this structure in the middle we can
see that there is plenty of space to
grow a compound at the edge of the
pocket so the chemist can then exploit
this information to see where they can
put a solubility group to improve the
physical chemical properties of these
molecules
and it and this was exactly what was
done in this case here
so
uh in the previous slide
it's a very specific example and now i
would like to
to go for a more general description of
how the project actu the process
actually goes
so
the project team
repeats a common workflow to optimize
the identified hits toward clinical
candidates
this is called the dmta cycle everybody
knows that fahama loves acronyms this is
the first one the mta and dmta means
design make test analyze
what exactly does that mean
so
if you look at the diagram what we can
see is that in the left
we have uh the heat which came from the
screening cascade
and this is the chemical starting point
for a drug
usually this chemical starting point
have several properties which are not
very attractive
it's it might be weak it might be poorly
selective it might have poor properties
and it might be toxic
and what you want to do during this
cycle is
design novel chemistry that's the design
step synthesize compounds that's the
make on the dmpa
put those compounds through assays and
determine structures
that is if the structural support is
enabled for this project
and then you analyze that and construct
a predictive model
that predictive model will tell you how
to make uh what to modify in the
compounds to start over the cycle
hopefully in the end of the cycle what
we we get is a candidate which ideally
is potent selective
effective in vivo
stable and safe
so
one of the problems here is that
to really get a good predictive
model
you need to synthesize a lot of
compounds the structural biology support
is really good because it can decrease
the number of compounds needed
to actually get a qualitative predictive
model at an earlier stage
so
we can cut for example synthesizing ten
thousand compounds to maybe synthesizing
uh
one tenth of that
the other consideration that we have to
do for uh the structural biology support
is that it's great to have a structure
but it needs to be at the right time
because the mta cycles are on the
constant pressure
to be sped up
so
let's go a little bit more into the
cryogem since i set the stage for you to
know what's the impact that structural
biology can have on the structure-based
drug design and on
on the clinical candidates
so
everybody was hugely excited
about
the possibility of having previous
intractable targets
especially membrane proteins um enabled
to structural biology by cryogem but
there was of course a lot of skepticism
and part of that was relating to the
question of
could we get high resolution structures
in the timelines that were suitable to
inform the project
uh to answer that i will uh start a bit
with the cryogem uh experience that
astrazeneca had
so
uh astrazeneca joined the cambridge
thermo fisher pharmacryom consortium
back in 2016.
this is a partnership among the mrc lmb
the university of cambridge thermal
fisher aztecs astrazeneca gsk heptaris
and ucb
um
we had access together with these five
other uh these four other companies two
cryos
that was housed at the university of
cambridge
so our
structure
writing
we realized right in the beginning that
many of the high resolution structures
required really large data sets of 5 000
to 15 000 images
and
especially at the beginning the
microscope time and the processing time
that
that it was required to actually get to
these structures
really limited the number of structures
that we could generate
so
at that stage what we had more impact on
was really really on the final heat
validation and characterization phase
so if you remember back to to the
diagram that i showed
this basically meant that we could know
the the binding mode and we instead of
going for several iterations we could
try to get some of that information
through computational methods
um
also right in the beginning
uh
very early on we faced two obstacles
that had to do with the computation and
the processing for front
uh
the number one was the fact that
achieving an optimal cluster computing
setup with a centralized it department
was not trivial
so a solution for that was actually to
find
an alternative and our alternative was
to invest in a software that was less
reliant on parallel computing
so we started a partnership with
cryosporix last year
the second was uh the fact that
transferring huge amounts of data
to our processing server was very time
consuming it was all based on disks and
uh and and you know transferring from
the microscope to the disk and from the
disk to
a computer and then to the central
server so
we uh we actually adapted that into a
workflow
with a transfer through aws
and that actually works really well and
it can go um
the transfer can go right by the side of
the data collection
so our
experience now is quite different from
the start from all of this that i've
been telling you through this slide
that's for several reasons first
some solutions i already told you about
but
there were several improvements on other
uh factors here
one was the improvement in the camera
throughput which has been extremely
impressive we now usually collect images
um
120 to 250 images per hour
we got increased microscope excess
uh this was increased when the
consortium invested in the second cryos
in 2018
and we had several improvements on epu
and on the ease of data collection
and that of course had an impact because
it frees up staff time for structure
determination and model building and
interpretation
so
this is uh the current state of affairs
of cryogem and astrazeneca just to give
you an idea of where you're standing
right now
so
at the current state
what we have is five projects with
cryo-em systems in place to generate
cost structures for chemical equity
optimization so we can really have an
impact on the lead optimization stage
and we
we can really
have several structures and really
inform
very thoroughly the process
this is because dozens of structures per
project are possible with the setup that
we have
and that really allows to build a
structure activity relationship model
so
if you remember the predictive mode of
building on the dmta cycle
this is what we are enabling now
with having all these
structures so
just for illustration
in an optimal case we can go from a
pre-optimized system
we can have data collection for one day
concomitant transfer and then two days
to obtain the map
and then another one to two days to
build the structure
so
that that takes us from um sample to
pdb in five days this is of course uh
the best case scenario
the average case
is that we get structures every
for one project every
second or third week and this is because
of several bottlenecks
the processing sometimes can take very
several rounds of 2d and 3d
classification that depends a lot of the
system
some of them even take a
very thorough 3d variability analysis to
get a high quality structure
sometimes we have
a lot of protein movement so
the building is much more complicated
than thought of and then you actually
spend quite a lot of time at that part
and the other factor here is of course
the scientist workload because we are
supporting several projects at the same
time and we also have to
cope with
data collection at the microscope
so on my final slide i just really
wanted to make the point that cryo-yam
is
delivering the promise is really
bringing previously intractable targets
into the realm of structure-based drug
design and this is not science fiction
anymore
so
i would like to thank you for your time
and i'm eager to
to hear some questions in the end but
now
i will give the word to brian
thank you tayanna
uh so i'm brian sherman
let me brian thank you
i'm in control still
oh there we go yeah
there we go
all right thank you thanks tayana so i'm
brian shervin i'm a solutions architect
at aws my focus is on high performance
computing uh and i'm going to talk about
some of the work that myself and my
colleagues natalie and steve have been
doing in the space of of cryo-em on on
aws
and so this this started uh sort of last
year when structure by biotechnology who
was a partner with aws
came to us and and wanted to know what
would cryospark look like on aws how do
we set this up what sort of the best
practices um help us out with this and
uh so we we proceeded to start to to
walk through sort of what their
requirements are and build a reference
architecture around that and a few
things came out of
of the crowd spark requirements the
first one is obviously access to gpus
and this was a bit of an interesting
problem because in some cases uh stages
in crowdspark scale well they scale over
multiple gpus and other stages are
single gpu only
and so that
having
there's a need for some sort of
flexibility in the compute resources
available uh the other point was around
storage so typically structure has
recommended that you have some sort of
fast local storage uh on the compute
nodes uh to enable uh you know have a
cache to keep those gpus fed with
cryo-oem data
and so
we we have
compute resources
available on aws that can address that
but not all of our ec2 instances have
that fast local storage and so there is
a question around do you always need to
use a specific instance type or or can
we can we mix and match different
storage options uh and and the answer is
yes and i'll get to that in a second
and then there's also some questions
around you know can we do this in a
cluster environment with single or
multiple users
and so what we what we came up with was
basically a reference architecture built
around a couple of aws services
particularly something called aws
parallel cluster and amazon fsx for
lustre which i'll go through in a second
and we we published a an architecture
with with structure as well as a set of
um benchmarks and cost analysis
so very quickly i'll go through
some of the core services that make up
this cryoem solution on aws
so the
the first one is aws parallel cluster
which is a
a way to easily con create configure and
manage
hpc clusters on demand
it is a it's a single uh command line
option and you you can spin up a cluster
from a single configuration file uh in
about 15 minutes and so it handles all
of the the sort of heavy lifting that
you would normally do to create a
cluster things like setting up a job
scheduler setting up cues
doing things like shared file systems
all of this is handled by parallel
cluster
and so you you basically just need to
pick certain options uh and press go and
create your cluster for you on demand i
can also do things like scale up your
compute nodes when you submit jobs and
then scale them down when you don't need
them so you're really only paying for
the compute that you use
and so all of that is is built on amazon
ec2 which is our elastic compute cloud
that's our range of different instance
types and i'll get into some specifics
on that in a little bit
i mention it here only because it does
make up our larger hpc services on aws
uh but we have something called elastic
fabric adapter this is a high speed
interconnect low latency
high bandwidth
interconnect
to enable these sort of tightly coupled
mpi type jobs that need to run you know
as a group on us on a collection of
nodes
that doesn't necessarily apply to cryo
at least to cryospark but we are
investigating other applications like um
to rely on where this can be made use of
and then the other key part to this is
amazon fsx for luster so if you're not
familiar with lustre
it's a
high performance parallel file system
it's fairly standard on most
hpc clusters around the world and we
offer a fully managed service for this
so it's
basically you you point it to a s3
bucket of data and select the size and
and you press go
it integrates very nicely with aws
parallel cluster and i'll show you some
of that in a little bit
and then the other actually one other
part to the hpc service on aws is
something called aws batch it's sort of
the um
the opposite of parallel cluster where
parallel cluster is designed for these
tightly coupled
mpi type jobs aws batch would be used
for sort of
large
independent parameter type jobs
and so moving on
so i just want to highlight a little bit
about the some of the ec2 instances that
we made use of we have we have a really
broad and deep platform of of um
instance types new over 400 types that
can be used for everything from machine
learning um to to big data to hpc
and this was a you know question that
that structure had what what do we use
um because not only do you have um do we
have you know we've got gpu options we
have cpu options but they also come in a
range of different sizes different
memory configurations different network
configurations uh and so the the
question was what what's going to work
best uh on aws for cryospark uh and the
answer um was a little bit surprising it
was
and i'll show you the benchmarks later
is
it the best approach is to use a mix of
gpu instance types for cryospark
you're not locked into one single
instance type um like you would be in a
you know in a workstation or an on-prem
cluster where you provision you procure
hardware and you're using that for a
couple years before you upgrade
with with parallel cluster we can easily
switch between you know low-cost nvidia
t4 gpus or if you need you can switch to
uh you know a larger
latest generation nvidia a100 gpu and
you can do that all within the same
cluster
and so i'll walk through in the
benchmarks a little bit more of the
specific gpu types
uh and so one of the other as i said the
beyond just the question about
you know compute resources structure
also asks us about data and this is a
problem that we we see with a lot of
customers in the cryom space and that is
just managing data you produce massive
amounts multiple terabytes of data
um how do you you know how do you
organize that how do you
you know get it to your to your compute
resources um
and in the past there's been a few ways
that people have done this
they can you can put it in s3 bucket and
then you may have to copy it to like a
local storage local disk attached to
your instance
maybe you're creating your own file
systems like setting up your own shared
file system or you might just be doing
something like running it directly from
s3
which simplifies things but you're still
having to run over a network connection
and there is a delay there is a
performance hit from doing that and so
this is where fsx for lustre comes in
because it simplifies this process
as i said it's a fully managed high
performance parallel file system
it connects to an s3 bucket and so the
idea is
you
you upload data to an s3 bucket it can
automatically be brought in to this high
performance luster file system which is
basically acting as a as a high-speed
front-end cache for that s3 bucket
it can give you you know access to
hundreds of gigabytes of throughput
basically for every terabyte of of
storage you get another 200 megabytes
per second a band of throughput we do
millions of operations on it um and
again the other key is this is all
managed um it basically is pointed to an
s3 bucket where your data is uh and
press go
and
there were some questions around you
know how would this perform versus the
the traditional approach that that
structure had gone with of using local
file systems
and so we we did this is one of the
benchmarks that we we tested so what
you're looking at is uh
basically luster performance versus
local drives on our r instances and this
is the percentage decrease in run time
so higher is better in this case and so
in nearly every case in this 2d
classification step uh and we chose this
2d classification step particularly for
this because uh it can use a cache
feature in crowdspark and it it will it
can scale across multiple gpus so we
wanted to see you know what was the
effect if we were running on a single
gpu or multiple gpus and you know we're
upwards of 50 over 50
performance improvement in some cases
with this
and i'm happy to get into some of the
technical details later in the questions
with this but the the short answer is
ava's extra luster allows us to decouple
storage from compute we don't have to
pick compute types that
have fast local storage we can go with
you know lower cost single gpu types if
that's what's required uh pair it with a
high performance file system
and still get good performance as
opposed to you know having to lock into
a single large instance type uh that has
that fast local storage uh so this is
actually a pretty pretty game changer
for um for structure and and what they
recommend now
the one thing i i want to highlight
and to just talk a little bit about what
tana had mentioned about problems with
data management
one of the great features with with fsx
for luster is this auto import feature
so
you can basically use s3 as a big data
like you're you're uploading data there
and you can automatically bring data
into your luster file system and you
have a lot of control over what gets
automatically brought in that can be
data that exists only in the bucket when
you create the file system you can bring
in new objects so you can imagine a case
where you are continually uploading data
from your cryo-em microscope into a
bucket
it hits the bucket it's automatically
brought into a high performance file
system uh next that's attached to your
compute nodes and you're running
something like cryospark live in um in
that fashion or you can even upload um
modified data so if you had to rerun
experiments upload new micrographs
process them that that's an option too
so this this managed auto import feature
can really simplify
some of these data management problems
that people are facing
and so when we put all this together uh
fsx for luster and parallel cluster
we came up with with this architecture
and we wanted to be pretty
straightforward and easy to use the idea
behind it was it it will look and feel
much like an hpc cluster that users are
used to uh but with again
it's all managed
and and easy to set up and
removes a lot of the heavy lifting and
sysadmini that you would have to do
so we we built this with the idea that
you'd have uh
multiple compute options so we have
multiple queues here that run a range of
different nvidia gpu types as i
mentioned we can run the latest
generation a100 gpus v100s and t4 gpus
and i've got benchmark data where you'll
see why having this flexibility is
important
we've also you can also add in
traditional cpus like our intel skylake
options uh to run on things like rely on
uh
we we've got a number of shared file
systems here the one i highlight in the
diagram is is for the cryoem data this
is our luster file system but there are
also a few others that are
more of your standard network file
systems this is for things like shared
home directory and application install
like where cryospark is installed
and
the the other thing i really want to
highlight here is that this is all
designed to be uh
uh created and and brought down uh with
with a single command line option uh it
it is infrastructure as code uh you can
manage multiple clusters from you know
single configuration files you can bring
them up when you need you can tear them
down when you need
you can you can automate their
deployment you can automate you know
file system creation the idea was that
this was meant to be flexible and that
you would only pay for the compute and
the storage that you need as opposed to
having to have
a
hvc cluster up all the time
uh and so and sorry the
color's wrong in the top part there this
was the benchmark that we did this is
the empire 10288 uh this is a
cannabinoid receptor it's a fairly small
benchmark uh we did this in part on
structure is recommendation but also
because we could run a large number of
simulations uh um and and so to get a
lot of benchmark data uh you can see the
pipeline that i ran there these were all
the steps uh and i ran this on
you know anywhere from one to eight gpus
uh and i ran this on all the gpu types
that i mentioned there the nvidia a100s
v100s and t4s
and i'll say there's
the full benchmark data is available on
cryospark's website they have a section
on there uh uh called crowdspark on aws
the whole reference architecture that we
built for them is there along with a lot
more of this the benchmark data um
basically i give breakdowns of the
performance of each stage of the
pipeline um but for for brevity's sake
i'm going to just show you a couple of
slides
by running a lot of these different
simulations we we got to see a view of
you know what what a cryo-em pipeline
looks like on aws because it's not
it's not like a lot of other hpc
applications where you're running one
single code and you need to see the
performance you know um for for that one
application um over a range of instant
um or sorry over a range of cpu count
this is you've got multiple stages each
stage is going to behave differently
some scale over gpu some don't some are
more affected by file systems than
others and so
what we're able to do is is put together
you know graphs like this where we see
how different stages scale as we
uh as we run on more gpus or as we add
in uh something like fsx for luster and
to sort of distill i've kind of
distilled it down to three points there
where you know we we saw certain stages
scale really well like patch motion and
patch ctf uh these are ones where you
would want to run on a larger
you know four or eight gpu option
there are other stages like 2d
classification or extraction where
running on a single gpu to save money is
sufficient you aren't gaining a lot by
running on multiple gpus and then there
are others where
like ab initial reconstruction and
non-uniform refinement where these are
single gpu stages and so
your your decision point there really
comes down to cost do we pay for a
a you know a newer larger gpu and and
get a faster timed solution or do we
want to save cost and go with like a you
know a lower spec
nvidia t4 or something like that and so
by by
running this this uh all these different
benchmarks we can start to put together
we start to put together uh different
cost analysis and i've got two examples
there this is by no means set in stone
but it's just meant to illustrate this
idea that
when you mix and match different ec2
instance types different
compute resources to the different
stages of the pipeline
you can you can work out a very you know
fast timed solution while still keeping
costs down so the chart on the left just
sort of shows what the total cost
including storage what the total cost of
each of those simulations would be if i
ran on a single instance type so for
example i'll i'll pick one um you know
the red if i were to run on four gpus on
this p3dn which is a
nvidia v100 gpu
i'm i'm at you know 128 dollars and this
was around three and a half hours of run
time
um but i've got you know other options
where it like in the in the um the chart
on the on the table on the right where
if i mix and match and do a little bit
of
you know benchmarking um i can i can run
on cheaper instances i can bring my in
some cases get my time to solution lower
and still save on cost
um and so so this was really exciting
for us we published this we've had a lot
of interest in this but what we really
wanted to see was what does it look like
on production data because as i
mentioned this is a pretty pretty small
data set and so this is where um
thermo fisher came in and so um i'm
gonna turn it over to ya because um uh
java actually
took what we what we built and actually
started to use it on real production
data which is exciting for us um and so
with that i will say thank you and i'll
table any questions for at the end and
i'll hand it over to eva
thank you brian
and hi everyone my name is java and
i'm an application scientist at time
official scientific
so
like everyone else we're really excited
to see these benchmarks and and we
wanted to see the how the technology
works
in our own hands and especially on big
data sets so today i will show you
three uh benchmarks in total one uh so
two public data sets which are available
empire and as one data set from thomas
fisher
and so
uh the first benchmark i want to talk
about is a carcitonin gene related
peptide receptor bound to its agonist
so it is a small membrane protein
74 kilodaltons and such small five
proteins are traditionally more
difficult to
uh process because they are small they
have less signal and
uh they might require more data or more
processing time to arrive the solution
so we thought it's uh it's a great
er it's a great idea to start with this
benchmark
uh downloaded the data from empire and
the dataset contained
5.6 000 movies from which i picked 6.3
million particles
and in total it took me four working
days to arrive at the solution and
that's because well it was the first
time i i saw this data or what this
routine had to think about
the right steps and
didn't work for the night so yeah it
took four days uh but if you look at the
time uh gpu
time that it took to rise the structure
was 36 hours and the final mass is 2.8
angstroms
and it consists of 1.4 million particles
so on the right you see two maps the one
in gray is from em database and the one
on the right is from the aws benchmark
uh and you can see there is definitely
an improvement in in resolution going
from the the public structure which
uh i would say is mainly attributed by a
non-uniform refinement
uh from from cryosport because because
it can really deal well with small
membrane proteins in
in my experience so all blessing was
done in cryosparca and on aws on a
p4 instant using a 100 gpus so we
this was not the does have work that
brian described where we just ran a lot
of simulations
we didn't
choose that path
um so the second
and second benchmark is also a gpcr but
this time a lot larger complex so it's
an active
uh glutagone like that type 1 receptor
and bound
to glp 1 and a g protein and similarly
to the best benchmark we downloaded the
data from
empire's
5.7 000 movies from which i picked
nearly 5 million particles and similarly
to the first example
it took me uh four working days to
uh arrive at their final match or
in other calculation uh 38 uh difficult
hours so the final math the shown in
blue with 2.7 angstroms containing 1
million particles and you can see it's
fairly similar to the
the published map showed in grey
and for the
final benchmark i want to show you
which shows a soluble protein that many
of you will will recognize so it's the
saskof to
spike in complex with a fat this was a
collaboration with
gaming chemical he developed an
anti-spike antibody and and sent us a
five derived from that antibody and we
did a structure of that in
uh thermo fissure so for this case we
collected the data
uh
in
in falcon 4 using er mode two and a half
thousand movies and on the fly
motion correction was performed
alongside data collection and
we were testing a different case here we
just uploaded the motion corrected
dose weight micrograph to amazon
and this was really fast and
then
i could pick
440 000 particles from this data set and
it took me
just half a day of of work of
submitting different jobs to cross park
to
arrive at at the final map and the gpu
hours accounted to six six hours in
total from
start to finish here the you can see
this 2.9 angstrom map of the spike core
on the right and it contains 64 000
particles
and
if you contour it at the lower level you
can also see that
the fabs can be identified bound to the
open conformation of the receptor
binding domain circled in red
so
next slide uh i want to show you a
breakdown of all birthing times and
cryospark and in these three examples
that i showed the the total runtime
uh was anywhere between five hours and
five hours forty minutes and one and a
half days and if we look at the
graphical representation on the right
you can see that uh
pre-processing steps uh and 2d
classification actually took the least
amount of time and the most
most time was
spent on 3d classification methods so
i pulled together heterogeneous
refinement and initial reconstruction in
this category which i both used to
select the best uh gpcr particles for
reconstruction
so um
i i do believe there is definitely some
way to
uh to make the process um even more
efficient the data are bursting workflow
more efficient and with some
optimization uh the repeat structures of
average or difficult cases may be
completed within
one to two days
okay and and so that brings me to my
last slide and i have i want to share
that you know i've been using
uh crest background aws for
for for some weeks now and i'm really
enjoying it especially because as brian
said you have a choice of
uh so many different uh tpu instances
and
you don't have the same bottlenecks that
you have you may have with data storage
and so on so um it is for sure faster
than the you know some of the in-house
solutions i've seen or
worked with so here are my conclusions
aws tile cluster and another flexible
lustre definitely offers the scalability
and fast performance for uh current data
processing and together with cryospark
it allows you to calculate sub3 angstrom
structures of large data sets
within hours to days uh i would say
definitely not weeks and and that means
that crime structures can be turned
around fast enough to be in sync with
medicinal chemistry cycles and actually
bring value to
structure-based drug discovery platforms
so i would like to thank all the people
without whom it would not have been
possible to do this work
so ali and sarah from structura and zara
from keeman chemical
uh all um all the people from aws so
brian natalie and stephen who really
guide us through our parallel cluster
setup and and all the steps to get
started and of course i'd like to thank
my colleagues for some official
scientific especially asian co and local
and central i.t teams who
uh helped with the data transfer and all
other i.t parts on our site so
thank you very much for your time and
i believe it is now time for questions
and i want to thank all of you for those
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar and if you have any
questions you want to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so welcome back all of you and we have a
couple other people joining us today
we have some great questions coming in
already so let's start with our first
question
what resolution do you need for lead
optimization
i guess that's for me
and any any of you can take these
questions um it looks like yes this
one's directed at you
um
yeah so so again we have to be a bit
careful with the average resolution
because
sometimes that's not very significant
but
looking at local resolution
i would say between 3.3
and higher than that you should be fine
wonderful thank you so much and
how do you decide how on the number of
rounds for heterogeneous refinements
i can take this one say
um
[Music]
i don't think there's any rules there um
just uh and i might also not be doing it
the perfect way but i use heterogeneous
refinement as fast 3d classification to
get rid of obvious giant particles so um
i ask the cryospark to
um
to divide my particles into a good class
and one or two bad classes and i see
how many particles in each round i'm
throwing out when that number becomes
very small then i'm confident that the
cycle particles is
is is good and then they go forward
thank you so much now brian this
question is for you does aws support
doctor docker um containers
and
go ahead
yeah uh so broad answer is yes uh
there's some specifics uh in there uh in
in parallel cluster uh yeah we can run
containers uh we generally recommend
using uh singularity uh and you're
welcome to ask follow-up questions on
that if you if you're not familiar with
it
uh it just that's mainly because it will
simplify some of the things around
running docker in a in a cluster the the
other option is aws batch that i alluded
to earlier is
it is designed entirely to work with
containers um
we we tend to see people use uh
you know batch less for cryo-em only
because um they tend to they don't
really have this need of doing large
embarrassingly parallel uh uh
applications they they usually need to
do like david did you know one kind of
in a couple of large intense runs and
they need to have some sort of
interactive approach to it
but in both cases yes we can run
containers
wonderful thank you so much and i want
to thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
um our next question yeah what
software did you use for the on-the-fly
motion correction of the third data set
prior for uploading
to
aws
thanks i should have mentioned that in
the presentation i used cryospark live
which is also a great piece of uh
software to
do on the fly analysis or off of the
data coming off the microscope so i used
that and that was run on just uh
a local machine with
4g views
thank you so much
and one more follow-up question for you
is uh eva the com the
computing process from frame alignment
to final high resolution map is it
completely automated
um
sorry um
i can repeat the question is it
saying is the computer process because
the the audience member says hi eva the
computer the computing process from
frame alignment to final high resolution
map is it completely automated
yeah
um yeah i wish i was i wish that would
be the case but um
there are definitely advancements
coming in but uh
there are decisions to be made there and
um
every step that the lebron described in
in this pipeline and that i showed that
you have to make decisions which
particles to take to the next step and
and how to tune it but but i think
especially in in the case of
routine analysis like repeat structures
uh there are definitely some ways to
automate the process and and to
streamline it to make you more efficient
sorry yeah we can just add a little
follow-up to that um yes
as you said we really can't automate
around the interactive parts but
i for for the benchmark i i ran you know
probably close to 200 different
simulations and
the way in the working cryospark on
parallel cluster is you can create the
next jobs that you want to run
link the output from the previous step
and krausspark will submit that and it
it submits a job to the scheduler on
parallel cluster which will provision a
node run the job and then tear it down
so as long as as long as you know what
parameters you need for the next step
and it's nothing that has to be
interactive you can
automate that to some extent and
parallel cluster will
automate provisioning the compute
resources um but it's yeah you s i'm not
a cryom scientist so i can't advise you
on what parameters you need to add in
you'd have to do that as well
and thank you so much for adding that
information and tayana this question is
for you do you use cryo-em for biologics
um yes um we do
we use it in a less intense way than we
use for small molecules so usually when
you're trying to optimize a small
molecule
you really need
several structures of the follow-up
compounds
and
in case of biologics antibodies and and
things like that
the affinity maturation is usually very
good already so it only comes to
structural biology support within
astrazeneca when there's something that
quite doesn't add up
so if there's a question if the antibody
it's not um
behaving in the expected way from from
the assays
then and it's a is a molecule of
interest then it comes to us but is not
as as
iterative
as for the small molecules
thank you so much
and again i want to thank our audience
we have so many great questions coming
in for our presenters
how about transfer cost are there any
transfer costs for uploading data to aws
i can take that one um so
in general data transfer into the cloud
um does not have a cost associated with
it unless you're using um one of our
like more managed services to do that
transfer but if you're directly
transferring data into
s3 um
there's a storage cost associated with
with it but the actual data transfer
itself doesn't have any additional cost
associated with it and what's great is
once you have the data in the cloud you
can use all of those cloud native
services or any additional applications
or software that you want to install on
your cloud infrastructure once the data
is already there
wonderful thank you so much and brian
this question is for you
is a new parallel cluster created for
each separate test and
how big is the overhead of this creation
deletion and or cost and they also want
to thank you for your presentation
thanks uh so
the answer is to your first question
about a separate cluster it it depends
um
what i did in this case was create a
single cluster and
run multiple jobs on that you you could
create individual clusters if you wanted
if you had a need for that maybe you
have different data sets different
groups of users that you need to you do
need to keep separate you could do that
um i mean that's the great thing about
how this is designed it's it's designed
to be
brought up used and created on demand
and so you can do that once for a lot of
people or do you know a lot of little
ones for individual users
in terms of the overhead
the probably the biggest overhead is
comes in the file system creation so uh
creating the luster file system involves
basically setting up um the back end of
some
ec2 instances that are going to manage
this luster file system for you and then
also uh some of the data import and
on on in general that's that's around 15
minutes it kind of scales a little bit
depending on how big of a file system
you're doing
but that's probably the largest overhead
in terms of
in terms of cost
really all that
you need at the bare minimum is this
head node that you log into and that's
where you interact with the cryospark
web interface and submit jobs you can
create a cluster that has zero running
compute instances at the start so you
don't need to have those up and running
uh until you're ready to use it so from
a cost standpoint the the the initial
cost on parallel clusters is can be very
low there's a lot of options that we can
tweak on that and i'm happy to you know
talk without offline but the the initial
overhead cost is pretty low in some of
the work that yavin and her colleagues
and i in in doing this we must have
created 12 15 different clusters and in
some cases we were tearing them down
rebuilding them tearing them and
rebuilding them in you know multiple
times in an hour phone call so it is
really
that easy to do it
that's what's great about the solution
is you can just configure it just from a
text file how many compute nodes you
need what the instance sizes need to be
it's very flexible
wonderful thank you very much now what
does the
dollar sign prices mean on the one slide
someone is asking
uh i'm just i'm
going to assume this is about the the
cost on the
the breakdown that i i gave
that that's the the total cost of what
your compute resources and your storage
um for that single simulation um and so
we basically just looked at you know
what what was the run time for this
entire simulation what's the price per
hour of that instance and that's how we
come up with it along with along with
storage so it's just to highlight this
pay as you
you only pay for what you use approach
thank you so much now we have time for
one more question um so that i can allow
you all to have some closing remarks as
well are there any plans to provide a
public hosted managed
um
cryospark version so you wouldn't have
to deploy it yourself
well
just checking which if one of the other
colleagues wanted to um
steve
yeah i'm happy about that um actually
that's an ongoing discussion that's more
sort of directly uh related to sort of
the crowd spot folks but we we are
discussing that with them as well so
we'll follow up with you on that um but
really that's that's the the structure
by technology folks as well
wonderful thank you and i want to thank
all of you for your presentations today
this has been a wonderful presentation
would you like to provide any closing
remarks i'm not sure if all of you want
to or how about if i just allow um any
of you to just say anything if you'd
like to add before we close
i'll jump in and just talk about the
partnership between all of the aws
people and and thermo fisher and
astrazeneca i think
sometimes if you haven't never run
anything in the cloud
it can be a little bit overwhelming
seeing all of the technology and the
acronyms and the instance types and the
costs and
i just want to
reassure attendees that aws has
resources and people to help you with
that
we've worked very closely with thermo
fisher to make sure that
you know brian is obviously focusing on
the hpc side but working with thermo
fisher's i.t personnel making sure that
all of the networking and data transfer
is happening in a cost optimized and
secure way
we have a lot of best practices
resources that are publicly available
training that's publicly available demos
and videos that are publicly available
so you can start your learning journey
wherever you are
and start building with the skills that
you already have and kind of learn new
skills as you go
so yeah the
the success that we've seen on this
webinar has just been phenomenal and
it's been really great to
talk about the results and see um the
significant
acceleration of the science that's
happening at thermo fisher and
astrazeneca so thanks everybody for all
the partnership that we've had in the
past few months and bringing this to
to light
you're welcome and did anyone else want
to comment
okay i want to thank all of you again
for your time today diana steve brian
natalie yeva all of you thank you so
much for your research and for your
important work
and i also want to take time to thank
lab roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcasts and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
we provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time stay safe
everyone take care bye